desde que estalló la guerra el apoyo de
occidente Ucrania ha sido inquebrantable
pero el país que más ha apoyado el
esfuerzo de resistencia ante la armada
rusa es Estados Unidos un estrecho de
manos entre Byron y selenski marcaría el
futuro de dicha cooperación la ayuda de
Washington akief a nivel económico y
militar ha modificado el rumbo del
conflicto
en el año fiscal 2022 el congreso
estadounidense ha destinado al Estado
ucraniano 65 mil millones de dólares y
lensky busca sellar un nuevo paquete de
ayuda en momentos en los que el congreso
debate el presupuesto para 2023 uno que
incluiría 45 mil millones de ayuda de
emergencia para Ucrania pero para
zelensky lo urgente van la ayuda militar
con un país sometido a los constantes
ataques aéreos rusos contra la
infraestructura eléctrica con la ayuda
de drones de fabricación iraní el
mandatario ucraniano aspira a concretar
el apoyo en defensa aérea por el que
viene clamando desde hace meses el nuevo
paquete ayuda incluiría bombas de
precisión pero ante todos los Terribles
misiles patreon sistemas de defensa de
tierra aire de largo alcance que pueden
alcanzar 24 kilómetros de distancia en
el pasado Estados Unidos ha entregado
armas como misiles stingers o javelings
y más adelante cohetes de alta precisión
como los Jaimes que parecen haber
cambiado el balance en el terreno
los Patriots suponen una defensa más
robusta pero también un objetivo
legítimo para las tropas rusas en
Washington Celeste ahogará porque el
apoyo a Ucrania se mantenga justo cuando
su país se adentra en un invierno de
consecuencias desconocidas y cuando en
Estados Unidos el balance de poder está
pocos días de cambiar pasando a
favorecer a los republicanos en la
cámara de representantes